from the origins of Optimus primal and
the threat of scourge to the influence
of the 90s TV series Beast Wars here's
all you need to know before seeing
Transformers rise of beasts
Transformers rise of the Beast hits
theaters in 2023. it was originally set
to premiere on June 24 2022 however the
seventh installment of the robot
franchise was bumped back by almost a
full year now the film is set to be
released on June 9th 2023 in the United
States Canada and the UK it will arrive
in some European countries including
Italy France and Iceland a little
earlier premiering on June 7. other
countries such as Australia and New
Zealand will have to wait a little
longer until June 22nd to see the film
June 2023 will be a pretty crowded month
for Blockbusters and Temple movies rise
of the Beast will find itself competing
against some pretty awesome 2023
releases such as Elemental Spider-Man
across the spider-verse and Flash rise
of the Beast has a comparable budget to
The Flash coming in at 200 million
dollars but with the controversy
surrounding the film's lead Ezra Miller
it's unclear how the highly anticipated
movie will fare so it won't be
fascinating to see if rise of the Beast
can defeat its theatrical foes and claim
the title of the summer movie Champion
rise of the Beast sees the Autobots and
Decepticons duking and out again while
also ushering in characters and a
different story to breathe life into the
franchise the seventh Transformers
installment which is set in 1994 will
follow a veteran named Noah a man who
loves his family and is looking for
Redemption from past mistakes the female
co-lead is named Elena a museum
researcher whose knowledge of artifacts
will know down Factor heavily into the
plot it's possible that through her work
she Noah and the Autobots discover the
existence of three new tribes of
cybertronians The Reptilian Predacons
the villainous Terror cons and the
heroic maximals who all make their debut
in this film while Optimus Prime and
Bumblebee have often been the most
notable Autobots taking the lead in the
original trilogy in the 2018 prequel
respectively its Mirage who forms the
closest bond with the humans in this
film there'll likely be Noah and Elena's
introduction to the Autobots same way
that bumblebee was for Sam whitwicky the
movie's official synopsis doesn't reveal
a lot but it does confirm that the
maximals will outlie themselves with the
Autobots in a battle against the terror
Khan's Predacons and Decepticons since
this is a prequel we know the heroes
don't succeed in wiping out the
Decepticons but fan favorite characters
like Optimus Prime and Bumblebee will
live to fight another day for the most
part the Transformers franchise is
Michael Bay's gigantic explosive
muscle-bound baby the Blockbuster up
tour helmed the first five films of the
franchise to huge box office earnings
and mixed critical Acclaim for the 2018
prequel bumblebee directing duties were
given to Travis Knight who also directed
the animated film Kubo and the two
strings now a third filmmaker will enter
the franchise as Stephen cable Jr is
directing Transformers rise of beasts
cable made his feature-length
directorial debut with 2016's land a
tale of four Teenage skateboarders
earning the wrath of a Crime Boss after
stealing a car full of drugs he followed
that up with Crete 2 which saw Michael B
Jordan's titular boxer grappling with
his past and battling a Russian Bruiser
he's also worked on the TV show's
Rapture and grownish speaking with Trey
Mangum of Shadow and act cable explained
what he's going for with rise of the
Beast saying there's a lot of heart and
emotion that I draw from if you've seen
any of my work I love to stay grounded
even though the scope could be here when
we're blowing up stuff at their core
Transformer stories are about good
versus evil truth Freedom the importance
of humanity and doing the right thing
even when it's hard these themes are
showcased through the unlikely Heroes
like Sam Kate and Charlie this will be
the case again in Rise of the beasts and
director Stephen cable Jr has made it
clear he wants a movie to show that
Heroes come in all different shapes and
sizes the entire creative team is in
support of this messaging and is Keen to
make sure audiences meet new Heroes and
aren't just getting another version of
the same old battle between the autobots
and the Decepticons producer Lorenzo D
bonaventura teased during an interview
with collider I want to start by saying
that what we're trying to do with this
movie is to give the audience a lot of
new if you've seen and been a fan of the
other movies you're going to see
villains you've never seen before you're
going to see Autobots you've never seen
before and you're going to see a lot of
elements that we've never done before
rise of the Beast brings a lot of new
elements to the big screen franchise but
one constant that viewers can count on
is Peter Cullen who is back voicing the
autobot Optimus Prime as a strong and
steady leader of the Autobots Optimus is
the common thread throughout the
Transformers franchise but leaning into
that theme of new viewers are going to
see a different side to him this time
around as a prequel There's an
opportunity for fans to see Optimus grow
as a character since at this stage she's
still figuring out his place on Earth
you've never faced anything like this
let them come his journey to becoming
the planet's protector is just beginning
during an interview with collider the
director said in this film it's forming
why he has a link to humanity and why he
has a link to Earth and that's emotional
it's not home yet to him he's like an
expat here he's landed he's alien and
he's never been here before that allows
us to get underneath the stoicism of
what we've traditionally presented in
crime and so at this stage he's going to
look less like The Optimist from the
Michael Bay films and much more like the
G1 robot viewers saw in Bumblebee along
with some returning cast members there
are some fresh faces as well the new
human lead characters are played by
Anthony Ramos of Hamilton and in the
Heights he stars as Noah Dominique
Fishback of Judas and the black Messiah
plays Elena despite being new to the
franchise both actors have long
histories with Transformers making them
perfect for these roles Ramos spoke to
people about his long love of
Transformers revealing that it was the
animated show beast wars that got him
into the franchise when he was growing
up he said I was in front of the TV
every week watching Beast Wars so when I
read the script I saw we were gonna have
them in the movie my head almost
exploded off my body meanwhile Shia
LaBeouf was fishback's window into the
Transformers Universe the Disney Channel
fan said in an interview with collider I
used to watch Shia on Even Stevens so to
watch him go from this Disney kid to
this movie star and being in the
Transformers films I was like oh man I
want to do something like that I
couldn't imagine that almost 20 years
later I would be doing it as well rise
of the beasts also boasts several other
notable cast members the Lord of
casterly rock himself Peter Dinklage
voices the villainous score Ron Perlman
plays the Silverback Optimus primal a
character he betrayed before in the
animated Transformers power of Prime
series Pete Davidson takes over the role
of Autobot Mirage from the late
Francesco Quinn and Michelle yo voices
erazor Optimus we must trust each other
to protect the home we all share one
character notably missing from this list
is Bumblebee who is voiced by Dylan
O'Brien in his 2018 solo outing
O'Brien's return to the franchise hasn't
been confirmed and his commitment to
other features like Ponyboy has no doubt
been keeping him busy however a voice
role in the movie is definitely not out
of the question and viewers may just
have to wait until the film is released
to get confirmation to tell this new
story The Creative team behind rise of
the beasts are introducing three new
robot tribes maximals Predacons and
terracons to the existing battle on
Earth between the Autobots and
Decepticons the introduction of these
new cybertronians will change the course
of the autobot Decepticon war that
viewers have seen so far Lorenzo D
bonaventura explained to collider we had
somewhat exhausted I would say that
battle so our Hope was how do we find a
new set of villains and a new set of
priorities for the villains however the
producer quickly noted that there were
lots of tribes and new characters from
the extended Transformers Universe who
had yet to be seen on the Silver Screen
the Predacons and terracons fall on the
side of the Decepticons while the
maximals are a new tribe of Heroes these
new Transformers turn into robotic
animals and birds Optimus primal is the
leader of the maximals and transforms
into a gorilla-like beast teasing a
little more about what viewers can
expect from these animalistic Heroes
kappel explained to USA Today in our
particular film there are these
prehistoric animals that travel through
time and space and we find them here on
Earth
Transformers rise of the Beast
introduces both the Predacons and
terracons as two new factions of
Decepticons but one should be feared
more than the other in an interview with
collider Capel said when the terracons
enter the screen and disrupt our movie
you're gonna feel it these robots are
the main villains of the film and they
are led by Scourge a merciless Predator
who takes pleasure in stealing insignias
from the Fallen Autobots he defeats Capo
was particularly excited about including
scorer she was a blank slate for big
screen viewers he said if Alex Scourge
was someone that was untapped that not
only allowed me freedom but it also
created the super rootless and scary
character scourge's right hand is the
shape-shifting Terracon night bird which
has been adapted from the Beast Wars
cartoon for the movie and according to
the director she's had some
modifications made to her she has a
vehicle form that is new but also
possesses ninja traits teasing more
about her history Lorenzo di bonaventura
said what I find interesting is that she
switched sides and now she's a Terracon
who has joined that side of it her
history is one that has had flexible
alliances which is fun it's pretty
common for Transformers to explore
different locations across the globe
showcasing how widely spread the robots
have become they don't just exist in
cities like New York and Chicago they
also hide out in the desert of Egypt and
Jordan as seen in Revenge of the Fallen
meanwhile age of Extinction took viewers
off to far-flung locations like China
and Iceland rise of the bees follows a
similar pattern the film traverses
continents taking viewers to locations
like New York and Peru additionally the
movie was filmed in a few more places
including Los Angeles and Montreal
however it was the South American
locations that most excited the film's
director he revealed to collider very
few films have been shot not only in
Peru but also Machu Picchu and they open
their doors for us I'm grateful to
collaborate with Peru and highlight
Peru's culture in the ancient
civilization they have beautiful
landscapes and sites but most
importantly beautiful people and I'm
excited about that this location is no
doubt going to be important for the
character of Elena as a museum
researcher this may be where she
discovers one or more important
artifacts relating to the terracons the
Transformers movie franchise sprang into
action in 2007 when Shia LaBeouf played
Sam whitwicky a shy but smart high
school kid but with the help of
Bumblebee Optimus Prime and their
transforming friends as well as Michaela
Baines Colonel William Lennox and agent
Simmons he became an earth-saving hero
the buff returned twice more with his
companions but in his third outing
Michaela was replaced by his new love
interest Carly this was Sam and Carly's
last appearance and director Michael Bay
went on to helm a new duology starring
Mark Wahlberg and Nicola Peltz Beckham
after this Travis Knight took the
franchise back a couple of decades to
1987 introducing a younger bumblebee to
Haley steinfeld's Charlie rise of the
Beast is set eight years after Charlie's
adventures with the Transformers
following the emotional ending of
Bumblebee which saw Charlie and B part
ways after saving the day together
Charlie chose to stay with her family
and friends while B had to embark on a
new mission of his own
after his adventures with Charlie
Bumblebee's new mission was to reunite
the autobots and it appears that in the
years since he has done just that
Transformers rise of the bees picks up
what the fan favorite robots back
together discussing how the setting of
1994 came about producer Lorenzo de
Bonaventure explained we were thinking
about it as a progression bumblebee was
in 1987 so then how do we move it
forward and also not run into the
timeline of the Bay films we had picked
94 in part because there was great music
during that time period so it felt like
that natural extension this fits
perfectly with director Stephen cable
Jr's vision for the film after reading
the script he felt very connected to the
time period and wanted to continue the
story he also noted that along with the
music bonaventura plans to capture
there's going to be a lot of 90s culture
and Aesthetics throughout the film so it
sounds like viewers can expect a great
Nostalgia trip from Rise of the beasts
Stephen cable Jr grew up watching The
Animated Transformers TV series Beast
Wars which ran from 1996 to 1999 and
since the movie takes a lot of
inspiration from the show it's no wonder
cable found himself at the helm he told
collider what brought me to the project
was the chance to imagine on a different
level and to dream that's what
Transformers means to me dealing with
robots dealing with humans and creating
that Bond it's all about the emotion and
where we can take our new characters
despite the inspiration Transformers
rise of the Beast takes from the 90s
show not every element of it is being
carried over exactly as it was for
Transformers fans who are familiar with
Beast Wars it's important to note that
the 2023 film has taken some creative
Liberties including introducing a whole
new crew of voice actors time travel is
one element from the series that cable
has indicated will be carried over
however it won't be in the same way
viewers have seen before movie's
timeline will differ from the one
established in Beast Wars which is set
300 years in the future every director
brings their own ideas and creativity to
a project Michael Bay did this with the
first five Transformers films putting
his unique stamp on the franchise and
delivering on the themes of heroes and
villains good overcoming evil and hope
overcoming loss but moving forward from
those films bonaventura said Stephen
cable Jr brought A must-needed New
Perspective he explained we were trying
to accomplish a certain change up from
the movies we did with Michael Bay we
want to deliver a film that has a scale
and spectacle of the Bay films with the
heart and humor that we were able to
achieve in Bumblebee the director's New
Perspective brought with that a darker
tone to the movie the fact that the main
villains have the word Terror in their
name should instantly instill fear
according to the director who is
planning to take that darker energy and
run with it he teased I want to dabble
more in horror in this one and make
people jump out of their seats
you can't stop the Transformers after
all they've earned over 4.8 billion
dollars at the worldwide box office and
they finally got some critical cred with
their last Venture bumblebee if
Paramount gets its way Transformers rise
of the Beast won't be the last time
these robots take over our theater
screens in February 2022 collider
reported that the official Paramount
Twitter account had announced rise of
the Beast would be the first installment
of a new Trilogy assuming it does solid
business chances are good we'll see Noah
Elena the maximals and Optimus Prime
back in the big screen again nobody I
ain't even seen nothing I'm not even
seeing anything right now a CG animated
Transformers theatrical film will also
follow in 2024 but is separate from the
upcoming Trilogy the upcoming animated
feature will be an origin story for
Optimus Prime and Megatron it will be
set on Cybertron and have Superman and
Krypton influences according to producer
Lorenzo Di bonaventura in an interview
with collider producer Lorenzo di
bonaventura talked about how much action
viewers can expect to see in Rise of the
beasts he confirmed that the film will
strike a nice balance of CGI in
Practical elements this means real-life
stunts which is where Anthony Ramos and
Dominique pishback's newly minted
driver's licenses might come in handy
alongside a stacked cast there is also
plenty of talent behind the scenes
joining Lorenzo diboni Ventura and
Stephen cable Jr is Joby Harold who
created the story for Rise of the Beast
and co-wrote the screenplay sci-fi fans
will know Harold best as the producer
behind the Disney plus series Obi-Wan
Kenobi he also worked as a writer on
DC's 2023 movie The Flash which is in
direct competition with this
Transformers feature additionally rise
of the Beast will be rated PG-13 like
all the other movies in the Transformers
franchise